wir haben von chaos berichtet dass alles
sehr sehr schnell hin dass plötzlich die
polizisten da waren und na ja viele der
augenzeuge mit wenig sprechen konnte und
auch geschrieben haben meinten dass sie
gar nicht wussten dass vorher eine
schlägerei hier zugange war dass die
dachten die polizisten sind aufgetaucht
um die partie zu beenden und corona
maßnahmen zu kontrollieren und allein
davon haben wir gesprochen was er uns zu
sagen hat dass er es war eine extrem
merkwürdige eigendynamik entwickelt hat
eine aggressive eigendynamik
ja ich kann den hass der priester
hinüber nur so vorstellen dass ganzen
kosten zu da gefällt ihnen die
möglichkeit an der alten oper feiern zu
gehen das tut den leuten aufgenommen so
mehr oder weniger sei es die leute haben
die letzte möglichkeit für einzigen
werden eben die alte oper und die
polizei sagten nein
und deswegen hat die meisten an ihrem
extrem hass gegenüber der polizei weil
einfach dieses letzte die letzte option
verein zu gehen einfach auch weg ist